Salut ! Comme tous les jours je vous donne une énigme pendant ces 32 jours d'été !
Et avant de vous donner l'énigme du jour, je vous donne la solution de l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, il faut foncer la regarder avant de connaître la réponse, sinon ça n'a pas d'intérêt.
Et la réponse à l'énigme d'hier est:
Chacun a prit le cheval de l'autre.
Et comme leur père avait dit: "Et celui d'entre vous dont le cheval arrivera en dernier, héritera de ma fortune"
ils ont tout intérêt à aller plus vite que l'autre, puisque l'autre a son propre cheval.
Vous comprenez l'idée ?
Chacun des deux frères a prit le cheval de l'autre à l'écurie, et c'est pour ça qu'ils foncent le plus vite possible.
Il fallait juste prendre en compte ce changement de cheval.
Bravo à tous ceux qui ont réussi !
Et ceux qui n'ont pas forcément réussi vous allez peut-être, être plus à l'aise avec l'énigme d'aujourd'hui.
Cette huitième énigme est une possibilité mathématique.
C'est-à-dire que 2=1.
On va prendre deux lettre: A et B.
A=1 et B=1.
Voilà comment je vais écrire toute une formule.
a=1 et b=1, ça veut dire que a=b. Jusqu'ici tout va bien.
En maths, on sait que si on met le même facteur à droite et à gauche, ça ne change rien à l'équation.
Donc je vais multiplier les deux cotés par a.
De la même manière si je retire exactement la même somme de chaque coté, ça ne change rien.
Donc je vais retirer b*b de chaque coté.
Maintenant à gauche, je vais rajouter 0.
Mais pas en écrivant 0, mais en le symbolisant par une petite équation:
a*b-a*b.
Si je changerai a et b par n'importe quelle valeur, ça ferait bien 0 quand même au final.
Et à droite je garde exactement la même chose, sauf que pour l'écrire d'une manière plus simplifiée, je vais mettre B en facteur.
Maintenant je fais exactement pareil pour la gauche, je vais mettre une mise en facteur.
Donc je ne change rien à l'équation, je ne rajoute rien, je n'enlève rien. Je mets juste une mise en facteur pour simplifier l'écriture.
Je vous le fais en deux temps, histoire de ne pas vous perdre.
Maintenant je refais une mise en facteur par a+b.
Donc je n'ai rien rajouté, j'ai rien enlevé.
C'est toujours la même chose.
Maintenant on va simplifier, c'est-à-dire que, effectivement en maths on met le même facteur de chaque coté, ça ne change rien.
Si on retire exactement le même facteur de chaque coté, ça ne change rien non plus.
Donc je supprime le facteur fois (a-b) des deux cotés.
Il nous reste donc a+b=b.
Et comme on sait que a=1 et que b=1, ça fait bien 2=1.
Et là on fait: "Mais non c'est un scandale ! C'est impossible !"
Je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous. Cependant la démonstration mathématique est bonne.
Alors pourquoi... A quel endroit y a t-il une arnaque ?
Je vous donne un petit indice, ne cherchez pas dans les mises en facteur, je ne vous ai pas embrouillé, elles sont correctes, tout est correcte.
Pourtant il y a une arnaque !
Laquelle ?
Ne vous inquiétez pas, je vous donne la réponse demain.
Je sais que celle-ci est beaucoup plus compliquée. Si vous avez la réponse, ne la mettez pas dans les commentaires.
Vous pouvez en parler, sans dévoiler la réponse pour laisser tout le monde chercher.
Par contre si vous avez trouvé, vous mettez un pouce en l'air, comme ça on sait quel est le nombre de personnes qui a trouvé ou était l'arnaque.
Pour terminer cette vidéo, vous pouvez compléter les phrases que je vais dire, en même temps que moi.
Ca me fais plaisir de me dire que vous connaissez la suite.
Profitez bien du soleil. Passez un bel été. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !